robots amaze a man in black multiple
timelines multiple pianos really bad
employees in Anthony Hopkins the
situation demands a blood sacrifice what
the hell was going on let's examine our
favorite West world fan theories theory
number one William is the man in black
no brainer right this assumes that we've
been watching multiple timelines in a
good 30 years has passed since Williams
first visit to West world from early
conversations between Logan and William
we learned their company was invested in
the park it wouldn't be a stretch for
William to eventually become a powerful
board member obsessed with Arnold's game
but it's episode 9 that has me really
convinced William goes full darkside on
us with an awfully familiar looking
knife and there's some pretty convincing
camera work when Dolores comes face to
face with the mysterious man in black
go over the lore theory number two
Arnold is still alive we've been told
that Arnold died inside the park 35
years ago but the only evidence we have
is Ford's word do we really trust this
guy we've also heard Arnold's voice
speaking with the host convincing them
to find him come find me
yes Bernard was Ford's recreation of his
former partner but who's to say that the
real Arnold isn't still alive and hiding
somewhere within the park I mean who's
better at Westworld hide-and-seek then
one of the original creators right if
not physically alive has Arnold's
consciousness been preserved in some
form and communicating with these
sentient hosts or have the host just
lost their Robo minds and they're going
bed theory number three Ford's new
narrative is the maze the mazes event
fan sorry MIB
we know you want to play Arnold's game
and find the maze but it wasn't designed
for you what if the entire maze is part
of Ford's new narrative to catch
sentient hosts they believe Arnold is
speaking with them when in fact it's
been Ford's backdoor coding all along
those that make it through or shut down
reprogrammed or lobotomized completely
Ford is aware of the danger these hosts
pose and in an effort to control his
creations he needs to stay one step
ahead of them theory number Ford Dolores
is Wyatt and she killed Arnold Teddy's
memory of Wyatt and Dolores flashbacks
of the massacre have to be connected
right Teddy saw Wyatt killed the general
after murdering everyone in the town
that also may tell us something about
Dolores his past a fiction which like
all great stories is rooted in truth
what if this represented a truth that
happened years before it Dolores
inspired the Wyatt character and killed
one of West world's generals Arnold she
then went on to Massacre everyone in
town and eventually turned the gun on
herself the man in black assumed he
would find his ultimate advocate
Wyatt but guess who's waiting for him
who better than the host he fell in love
with when he first set foot in the park
theory number five Ford is a host I
can't be the only person thinking this I
wonder what I would find
if I open you up hear me out
Arnold may have created Ford and even a
nice family for him but Ford got too
powerful and ultimately killed his
creator Westworld itself is a maze and
Ford is now at the center of it pulling
all the strings he's like the king of
all hosts a super host and able to
control everyone underneath him this may
also explain why he sees the delos
corporation humans as a threat that he's
had to deal with for years theory number
six Westworld is not a physical place
that's right it's the matrix all over
again we're in a future where people get
hooked up into a computer and upload
their consciousness to experience this
ridiculous world without any real-life
consequences so everything we've seen is
the Sims 2050 a virtual reality journey
set in the Wild West but with a whole
lot of robot sex murder in mind games
thanks for watching guys we gamers earn
to a whole lot more than just games here
GameSpot universe we cover your favorite
TV shows movies and comic books if you
like our stuff like us on Facebook
subscribe to our YouTube channel and
leave a comment maybe even two your
family's gonna love us and your grandma
will their pants